du wirst mir nie ein kind nach ein
echtes kind der film über den wir reden
heißt emma hat ich gehörte er kennt das
ist ganz schön viel los in dem bericht
und es ist eine art adoptions thriller
ist es weggeworfen
es ist aber auch musik film und
überhaupt sonst auch alles andere was
kino kann es ist ein horrorfilm es ist
ein krimi
und jetzt handelt von einem paar nur 1 1
ist schuld dass wir ihn nicht ausstehen
konnten erkannte das gesehen sie ist
tänzerin er ist tanz direktor
wir haben ein kind adoptiert das kind
ist unglaublich irre und stellt
furchtbare sachen also geben das kind
wieder weg und du allein bist schuld
dass ich fürchterliche schmerzen hat
dann fällt ihnen eigentlich wollen das
kind aber doch weil sie selber auch
freaks sind wie das kind und dann müssen
sie eine neue familie bauen dann müssen
die familie herstellen wie es noch nie
eine gegeben hat weil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mehr
es gibt noch ein zweites kraftfeld in
dem film außer das was um diese emma
wütet die tanzt dass das gar nicht
glauben kannst die spielt dass das gar
nicht glauben kannst und das ist eine
frau die sie verführt weil sie eben
ihren unfassbares landa verfolgt das
spielt eine polin die anime geht das auf
eine weise macht das du sozusagen eben
diese zwei pole hast dieses dieses feuer
diesen flammenwerfer diese explosion das
verrückt ist ist eigentlich dass das
eben ein total brutaler heftiger
intensiver film ist wer trotzdem happy
end hat wo aber viele spieler philister
konservative gestalten sagen das doch
kein happy end ist eine katastrophe
doch ne pn kann ich auch nicht machen
richtige [ __ ] weil wir so tanzen
pablo larraín der regel das ist ein
mensch der sehr oft von genie gehalten
wird wenn man das jetzt nicht einfach so
verteilt wie irgend so ein prädikat
besonders wertvoll oder so mit jenny was
meint und bei paul ryan habe ich immer
das gefühl gehabt der hat eigentlich
alle mittel für einen genialen künstler
aber die filme waren es dann irgendwie
nicht sondern hatten wir so genial
schatten oder genial kreusel er hat sich
häufig ganz ganz schwere
zeitgeschichtliche stoffe vorgenommen
post mortem zum beispiel handelt von
diesem faschismus in chile dann
jackie mit natalie portman hatte von
jackie kennedy
da an der club auch ein sehr intensiver
film von eben handelt von katholischer
kirche und kindesmissbrauch also lauter
so giftigen es in dem man eigentlich so
gerne anfassen du kannst aber nicht
immer machen was du willst du darfst
mich nicht allein lassen
du darfst das nie vergessen niemals
dafür wäre ich schon sagen und bei ihm
dachte ich immer der iss zu smart dieser
film macht jetzt solche sachen wie das
eben der bernal an einer stelle sonst
marten vortrag hält als der tanzkurs
schussgewalt eine kultur in der frauen
komplett zu sexual objekten degradiert
werden und der mann ist ein blöder mag
zu den frauen die ganze zeit über immer
wieder seine faust in den arsch toller
immer wieder genau das wollen sich so
ist dieser rhythmus dumschat unter druck
gibt ihr die kohle gibt mir ein auto
gibt mir gibt mir gib mir und die frauen
die bande um emma also eine frauen bande
die sich gebildet hat ihm dann seine
ganze gescheit haid einfach ins gesicht
tanzt also das heißt eine tanzszene der
tanz montage wie man selten gesehen hat
antwortet auf so ein
ich bin ja so schlau und kann das alles
analysieren das heißt in gewisser weise
zertrümmert dieser regisseur seine
eigene raffiniert haid und und
intellektualität einfach mit intensität
in diesem film und das ist so eine
freude und das ist so fantastisch wenn
jemand so klug ist und das dann aber
auch noch nicht für alles hält so
produktive was willst du mehr
[Musik]
in diesem film sollen alle menschen
gehen die in einer familie aufgewachsen
sind oder eine gründen oder einer aus
dem weg gehen denn es ist tatsächlich
auch ein familienfilm und zwar in dem
sinne dass die ma halt eine familie will
und nicht wie irgendwelche 68er hippies
wilhelm reich beschwipsten sagen die
familie ist ein unterdrückung instrument
und wir müssen sie zerstören sondern
viel schlimmer sind sie will ich keine
familie wir sind eine komplett an
gewusst dass du da gefunden das den
menschen halt nicht flügel muss und ich
habe ja ein jüngeres kind adoptieren
wollen aber dafür was du zu halten du
hast den jungen total verzogen
gezeigt wie man ein feuer legt es gibt
ja einige filme und fernsehserien von
transparent über life unexpected mit der
auch nicht schlecht
appleby bis zu diesem winter bergfilm
die kommune die da so rum eiern um
dieses thema wie könnte man den
familiengeschichten anders erzählen für
die anderen familien die es heute gibt
regenbogenfamilien patchworkfamilien
überschreitende familien was weiß ich
was für familien und dieser film nimmt
sich einfach dieser film sagt einfach
sie will eine familie sind eine andere
familie als didier vorgesehen ist und
alle denen das nicht passt sollten sich
echt in deckung irgendwie begeben wenn
diese frau angetan ist kommt also wie
gesagt wenn eine familie interessiert
oder aber nicht interessiert da
reingehen denn danach interessieren
erst einmal herausfinden was ich tue und
wieso wirst du jetzt zeitnah
[Musik]
sie setzen also wir waren damals in
venedig in diesem film als pressefotos
und sind da raus gegangen und alle
dachten irgendwie ja das war jetzt das
festival besser wird es nicht mehr es
wird dann auch nicht mehr besser ist
wurde noch ziemlich gut aber besser geht
halt auch nicht
und dann haben wir jetzt im grunde die
ganze zeit darauf gewartet waren der ins
kino kommt und dann denkt man natürlich
immer so ein bisschen als jemand der
eben auch das amerikanische und
mainstream und hollywood blockbuster
kino mag
schade eigentlich dass das dann mit
sicherheit in irgend einer woche von
james bond oder marvel erschlagen wird
das wird es jetzt nicht jetzt hat es
wirklich die chance diese intensität und
dieses feuerwerk das darin stattfindet
als so eine sensation erleben zu lassen
wie das sonst wäre wenn man zwei stunden
lang spezialeffekte um die fresse
gekriegt und ich kann nur sagen leute
bitte reingehen wir bekommen doch klar
oder kommt er ja alles angehört wir
brauchen doch nichts die leute lieben